welcome back everyone this is part six
in our series on grounded language
understanding we're going to be talking
about neural rsa which is our
combination
of the rational speech x model with the
kind of machine learning models that
we've been focused on for this unit and
i'm hoping that this draws together a
bunch of themes from earlier screencasts
and also sets you up if you choose to to
apply these ideas in the context of a
original system or a final project i'm
going to be talking in a general way
about these ideas they really emerge
from the papers that are listed on this
slide and the full references are given
at the end of the slideshow
now what's our motivation here recall
that in screencast 4 i presented a bunch
of tasks that i claim would benefit from
the back and forth reasoning that rsa
offers grounded in specific context and
those tasks included discriminative
image labeling
image captioning machine translation
collaborative problem solving
interpreting complex descriptions
especially navigational instructions and
maybe even optical character recognition
and i think we can think of other tasks
that we could put into the mold of like
the colors in context task and really
benefit from the mechanisms that rsa
offers
however as we saw at the end of the rsa
screencast there are some obstacles to
doing this rsa is standardly presented
as not especially scalable
it's also not especially sensitive to
the kind of variation that we're likely
to see in actual usage data in the
large-scale corporate that would support
these tasks and relatedly it just
doesn't have any notion of bounded
rationality even though of course once
humans interact they're not perfectly
rational even in the pragmatic sense
that rsa offers
and there's another dimension to this
problem for motivation here which is
that rsa harbors a really powerful
insight and we might hope that we can
achieve more impact for that model by
bringing in new kinds of assessment for
it you know taking it out of the
psychology and linguistics lab and into
the world of ai and in turn achieve more
impact for rsa and maybe show more of
the scientific world that rsa has a
really powerful insight behind it but of
course to realize all of this potential
we're going to have to overcome some of
those core issues of scalability
and that's what i'll show you here i
think i can offer a simple recipe for
doing that and testing out a lot of
these ideas
to make this concrete let's continue to
ground our discussion in our core task
which is this colors in context task
just recall that if you're playing the
speaker role you're presented with three
color patches one of them privately
designated as your target and your task
is to describe that target in that
context for a listener and then in turn
the listener task is given the three
patches and no idea which one is the
target and a speaker utterance use that
utterance to figure out which was the
speaker's target so you can hear in that
description that this is potentially a
kind of communication game that would
support the back and forth fourth
reasoning that is the hallmark of the
rational speech x model
so how are we going to take this task
and rsa and combine them well the first
step is straightforward we're going to
start with a literal neural speaker i've
given that as s theta up here with
literal literal indicating that it's a
base agent
and for this it's just going to be
exactly the natural language generation
system that we explored in the earliest
parts of this screencast right except
now we're going to consume three color
patches with the target always given in
the final position
and then the decoding task is to offer a
description we can make a lot of
different model choices here but the
fundamental insight is that we can now
treat this agent as a kind of black box
based listener instead of having to hand
specify a semantic grammar which would
be impossible even for the
task the size of the colors and context
data set we now just train an agent and
use it to play the role of the base
agent and we can of course do the same
thing for the neural literal listener
we'll again have some parameters theta
which will be represent this entire
encoder decoder architecture this neural
literal listener will process incoming
messages as a sequence
and then given some context of colors
and a scoring function make a guess
about which one of those three colors
the message that it had as input was
being referred to and again instead of
hand specifying the lexicon we just
treat this agent as a black box it
serves the role of the literal listener
and from there the rsa recursion so to
speak is very easy to apply let's
consider the base case of a pragmatic
speaker
so you can see over here we're going to
use our trained literal listener
and this is the most basic form that the
speaker can have
and we've just got now a pragmatic agent
that is reasoning about states of the
world as inputs and making message short
message choices on that basis and it's
doing that not in terms of the raw data
but rather in terms of how the literal
listener would reason about the raw data
so that core rsa insight
but we're just essentially using l0 here
as the mechanism to derive the speaker
distribution
now there is one catcher as we discussed
in principle for rsa this would be a
summation over all messages which would
be completely intractable for any
realistically sized language model what
we can do to overcome that that
obstacle is simply use our train literal
speaker which i presented before and
sample utterances from it and that small
sample will serve as the basis for this
normalization down here so it's an
approximation but it's an easy one given
that we have this trained agent down
here and in practice we've seen that it
does quite well in serving as the
normalization constant
and then the neuropragmatic listeners
are even more straightforward having
defined that pragmatic speaker to put a
listener on top of that is really easy
again you essentially just apply bayes
rule and you get a listener out
and in the monroe doll paper as you've
seen we actually found that weighted
combinations of the literal listener and
the pragmatic listener were the best
they were the best at the colors and
context tasks
let me just close up by mentioning a few
other related strands of work that you
might think about bringing in what i
just showed you is the most basic form
of this but many extensions have been
explored
so goland in all 2010 is a really early
paper in the history of these ideas that
is quite forward thinking they explore
recursive speaker listener reasoning as
part of interpreting complex utterances
compositionally
with grounding in a simple visual world
and i love the connection with semantic
composition this wagon all 2016 paper
does even more of that pragmatic
reasoning helps in online learning of
semantic parsers
i mentioned before work by stephanie
kellex and colleagues on what they call
inverse semantics which is a simple rsa
mechanism applied in the context of
human robot interaction to help humans
and robots collaborate more efficiently
kanye i'll extend this to kind of more
free form social interaction by showing
that rsa has a role to play in
collaborative games
i mentioned before this work by ruben
cohen gordon and noah goodman on rsa for
translation
uh ruben cohen gordon did a lot of
innovative work as part of his phd in
the context of rsa he also explored
applying rsa at the word and character
level so removing the approximation that
we sample from the s0 speaker to create
the denominator rather instead he
applies rsa at every single time step in
a left to right sequential and decoding
step and that time step could be either
the word level or surprisingly it was
very effective at the character level
and then these final two papers here
just show that we could move out of the
mode of pre-training the base agents and
applying rsa on top
and instead have a mechanism of
end-to-end rsa learning which is more
ambitious in terms of learning and model
setup but provides more chances for us
to be responsive to the nature of actual
usage data while still making good on
the central insights of rsa and with
luck seeing some empirical benefits from
doing that